twitter facebook et instagram snap chat
with spotify youtube
bref tout donald trump est bloqué sur
tous les réseaux sociaux on y est
les gars femmes sont devenues tellement
puissante qu'elle peuvent désormais
techniquement empêcher n'importe qui de
s'exprimer ou tout simplement d'avoir
une existence sur la toile même le
président des états unis
alors évidemment il a fallu donner des
explications le pdg de facebook mark
zuckerberg a donc donné la sienne
les évènements choquants de ces
dernières 24 heures prouve que donald
trump entend user du temps qui lui reste
pour saper la transition pacifique des
pouvoirs avec joe biden nous pensons que
laisser le président utiliser nos
services durant la période de transition
représente un trop grand risque
le contexte a changé nos plateformes ont
été utilisée pour inciter à une
insurrection violente contre un
gouvernement démocratiquement élu
alors déjà prouve n'ont ils rien qui
prouve rien du tout l'invasion du
capitole par une meute de partisans de
trump était pour lui plutôt une épine
dans le pied qu'autre chose c'est pas
vraiment dans son intérêt twitter
explique quant à lui que le compte du
président est fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
parce que trump a posté auparavant un
tweet dans lequel il qualifiait les
assaillants de patriotes et donc cela
veut dire que quelque part il les
soutient et donc ça peut envenimer
davantage la situation et provoquer
d'autres incidents oui mais enfin on
n'en sait rien ce sont des suppositions
ni plus ni moins les grandes plateformes
de réseaux sociaux empêche littéralement
à président sortant de s'exprimer en se
basant sur des suppositions
si les tweets ne sont pas supprimés le
comte restera verrouiller les violations
futur eu des règles de twitter
entraîneront la suspension permanente du
comte de donald trump se croirait au
lycée quand on invoque la censure au nom
de la liberté c'est ya quand même un
problème quelque part chez nous en
france cette opération des réseaux
sociaux contre trump ont fait réagir la
classe politique évidemment stupéfiants
comment en sommes nous arrivés là que
les gaffes à décide seul hors de tout
contrôle de tout recours de qui peut
bénéficier du droit d'expression est
inquiétant la fermeture du compte de
donald trump par twitter si elle peut se
justifier par une forme de prophylaxie
d'urgence n'oppose pas moins des
questions fondamentales
la régulation du débat public par les
principaux réseaux sociaux au regard de
leur seul cgu alors qu'ils sont devenus
de véritables espaces publics et
rassemble des milliards de citoyens
cela semble pour le moins un peu court
d'un point de vue démocratique au delà
de la haine en ligne nous avons besoin
d'inventer une nouvelle forme de
supervision démocratique
on peut combattre trump et le chaos
qu'il a entraînés mais refusé de se
réjouir de voir les gaffes a décidé seul
sans contrôle du juge sans recours
possible quel président en exercice a le
droit d'avoir un compte ou non sur
twitter cela n'aide certainement pas la
démocratie
twitter suspens le compte de trump de
façon permanente dans l'ordre des
atteintes portées à la liberté
d'expression dans une démocratie c'est
la plus grave jamais commise
attention le bâillon de l'un peut
devenir la muselière de l'autre
battons-nous contre la censure
j'ai des tests trump je déteste ses
idées mais qu'il ne puisse s'est exprimé
sur twitter ait qu'un chef de l'état
encore en activité se fasse en sueur et
ça pose un sujet effectivement ça pose
un sujet sommes nous vraiment en train
d'entrer définitivement dans une ère où
une grande multinationale pourra décider
de la politique d'un pays
j'ai l'impression que les prochains mois
risquent d'être assez cocasse